all the men to cheat
John Kramer
the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid
there's nothing else we can do there is
one person who might be able to help our
program is a two-pronged treatment
outside Mexico City the results have
been stunning she saved my life
you're in very good hands with us
after that what happens then your whole
life happened John Kramer
according to these scans
the tumor was never removed how much
time do I have
months at best I still have a lot of
work that needs to be done
[Music]
hello everyone it's time to play a game
you all pretended to cure me the one I
have planned for each of you is very
real
no light
no sound the only thing I have not
provided is your anesthetic but trust me
you will want to remain alert
[Music]
out of all the men to cheat you picked
John Kramer please don't hesitate
place a big enough piece of your
cerebral tissue into the glass enzyme
tank this will save your life
is not retribution it's a Reawakening
[Music]
live or die the choice is yours